[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the ft's
whitehall editor sebastian payne
and the economist senior editor anne
mcelvoy
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
as the government reportedly prepares to
make anti-covered measures like
mask wearing and social distancing a
matter of personal responsibility rather
than law
the mail proclaims freedom is in your
hands now
the telegraph has the same story again
with the emphasis
on individual responsibility
there's a backlash from the government's
own scientific advisers who disagree
that all restrictions should be lifted
according to the guardian
the sun links the goodwill towards the
england football team
with the happiness many people are
likely to feel at the loosening of
restrictions
and the financial times has word that
china's internet regular has banned the
taxi app
diddy for allegedly violating rules on
personal data collection
and we're joined tonight by sebastian
payne and anne mccalvoy
there they are standing by welcome to
you both good evening
let's start with the mail front page uh
and that um
headline really talking about personal
responsibility
and saying that it's up to the
individual now whether they
decide to continue wearing masks or not
it will no longer
be obligatory sebastian
so this is the announcement that's
coming from boris johnson tomorrow about
the next stage
of the easing of lockdown restrictions
which is due to take place
on july the 19th now we will get a
formal indication on july the 12th where
this is
actually going ahead but this speed this
speech or i should say press conference
delivered by boris johnson on monday
is effectively going to say yes the
easing is happening on july the 19th and
we are going to move beyond the point
of when the government tells you exactly
what you can and can't do
to the level of individual
responsibility the reason we're moving
to this stage is clearly because of the
massive success of the vaccination
program
and the vaccines themselves that over
half of british adults have now been
double jabbed and basically reports
being single jabbed as well
so when society opens up again and the
coronavis begins to spread rapidly
it will hit a wall of vaccinated people
that's the government's argument but as
i'm sure we'll get into
as many other scientists who don't quite
agree with that and think they are
moving
a little bit too quickly but it is a
remarkable change in tone from the
government
that even just a couple of weeks ago
when they had to delay that reopening
from june the 21st
july the 19th they were talking about
the dangers ahead the issues of the
delta variant
and the need to be cautious now we're
back to boris johnson's boosterism
accompanied by sanji javid the new
health secretary with a full steam ahead
approach and as you said the key things
are the mandatory face masks will go
the one meter plus social distancing
rule will be dropped and it will no
longer be
law that you should work from home yes
and the telegraph also
going with that story and the headline
use your judgment um the pm
is is urging us to do so um but
as sebastian was alluding to there that
the scientists have something completely
different to say
well this has always been the big
argument isn't it is really do
you say to people once you start to get
a high level of vaccination
take it make your own decisions you'd
take some risks be aware you're
taking a risk the scientific evidence
has
been rather cold on that and so if
you're going to
deal with this and you're reaching a
point where you're getting towards
a strong immunity but it's never
complete we do know even on 90
immunity in a fair number of people are
going to catch kevin and you're then
kind of hoping
against i suppose some of the trends
that we've seen with the delta variant
that you can catch any new variant of
the disease
as well as suppressing what you might
call the original covid that we all
talked about
a year ago so this is really quite a
gamble that the prime minister is taking
here i understand why he's taking it
it's a sign
of how much he feels under pressure from
businesses
from his own back benches it's hard to i
think to overestimate how much political
pressure
there is on the prime minister and that
that modeled it it looked at a lot of
public opinion whatever people say pro
and con people do
often feel that it's just becoming too
much they've lived with it long enough
and they want
to have some of their liberties back the
prime minister's decided
on this occasion to go with that punch
as opposed to
going with this scientist but no
questions disagreement on it
yes indeed and to the guardian and
they're obviously quoting
the the number of um cases that they're
having
risen to the highest level since january
2021
and again the scientists saying that
it's it's really i think the quote was
bonkers
to be taking the foot off the pedal
sebastian
at this time in particular of course you
know we've always had this debate with
scientists on both ends of the spectrum
saying that
you know there are risks involving every
turn of this and there was a piece but
in the mail on sunday today by
sanji javi the new health secretary who
was pointing out the very tough
economic and health cost of continuing
to lock down
and it does feel as if the debate has
shifted quite a lot partly
by his arrival replacing matt hancock
but also i just think the fact that you
know you can see the success of the
vaccination program
the thing that i think i'm the question
that's going to have to be answered is
when we do reopen everything again and
coronavirus starts to spread we're going
to see very high levels of infection
we're already at
24 000 cases a day and it's not beyond
the realm to expect that to easily
double again
when society is opening up and i don't
know how people are going to feel about
that because
we've been living with this constant
thing of infections that then lead to
hospitalizations but then lead to death
i think one of the key messages that
boris johnson will be saying on monday
is that yes we can have lots of
infections but thanks to the vaccines
and thanks to other medical advances
that's not necessarily going to lead to
hospitalization
and further deaths from coronavirus but
it is going to be quite a big change
in society and i think that you will
always see scientists on both sides but
the fact is
i don't think boys johnson is going to
do anything that his chief medical
officer chris whittie and the
chief scientific officer patrick
violence aren't going to go along with
there's a cabinet meeting
tomorrow where they're going to sign off
on this plan and as i said it won't be
for another week until we get the formal
goal that this thing is going to happen
but there was a clear direction of
travel i think what is going to be
interesting though is what is still
recommended and i think it's on the
front page of the telegraph
they're saying that in fact that it's
still going to be recommended to wear
face masks in
tight crowded spaces and for one thing
whenever i get on the tube to go into
work now in london i'll probably still
wear a face mask because it's not the
healthiest environments of the best of
times
but and still the messaging and also
leading up to
to announcement next week to people has
been
that the the pandemic is over suggesting
that you know if you don't have to wear
masks you don't have to social distance
people will behave
as if it is all over and it clearly
isn't
the difficulty is if you say if you take
that example face mask is a very
good example some people feel almost
kind of ideologically about it
others just feel i find it probably
increasingly a bit
a bit of a bit of a far frankly and
probably the last minute leaving the
house i have to think do i have it with
me
or not so what happens then how many of
us then
on the whole when we go into those
crowded spaces as sebastian was
describing going into the tube or maybe
going into
something that is a gathering where
people are moving around in front of
each other social gatherings which are
rather different from sitting facing
forwards is
how many of us do and how many of us
don't and i think that must be
a worry if you're a behavioral scientist
because it's all right to say
make your own decisions and assess your
own risk
but we do know that we tend to copy each
other we might be a bit resentful as
human beings but we think oh god do i
have to do this again
but actually we tend to do what most
other people do
most of the time and trying to get to
that balance is something i think
will be difficult i mean one should
reflect the other side of the argument
that
we were told that if this vaccination
worked and the rollout has been very
fast
it's still ongoing there are still
hiccups along the way the delta variant
came along in the middle of it
people will say at some point well i
suppose on the scientific evidence we
should never entirely
uh give up on these restrictions at all
and at some point you do
have to live with coveted the question
is
how do we live with covet it's not so
simple as saying we just should live
with it
what do we still have to sacrifice more
don't we yes
and uh it's been reported that that some
of the scientists are
apoplectic of the fact that uh sergey
javid has likened it to
to dealing with the flu sebastian
in the mail they've got a double page
spread and they're really pitting
sanji javi the health secretary against
the scientists sajid vs
sage doomsters well i think he didn't
actually
uh directly to the flu i think it's
remarkably a little bit misconstrued
that we should just keep an eye on that
because obviously covert is not like the
flu it is far more deadly it spreads far
more quickly and
and i think anyone who does compare it
to that has obviously missed the past
year and a half of our lives because we
wouldn't have been in lockdown
if coronavirus was just like the flu and
it
is a very interesting one for sanji
javid because he had
noted some of the issues with lockdown
and the health and economic effects a
long time ago
when he was a backbench mp but he's come
into this job and either on his own
authority or with authority of boris
johnson has taken a really different
line to matt hancock because matt
hancock
was very cautious at being very and
prescriptive in terms of
how the rules should be followed what
the rules are the importance of lockdown
where sanji javid has you know literally
from his first day going to the
department of health
has been saying we need to live with
this thing we need to get freedoms back
as soon as possible and of course he's
been a very lucky general
in the sense that he's coming just as
the vaccination program is you know
creating that wall of immunity around
the country
and but i think there is going to be a
lot of disquiet and if we do go ahead
and we do see that rise of infections
you can imagine a lot of scientists
saying well we told you so but the real
test for this is going to come
in the ultimate winter that once covered
starts spreading and it's made its way
through the population we've then also
got the flu we've also got this backlog
the nhs has a backlog of
five million operations which is huge
and that's got to be worth doing
mr javid has said it is going to get
worse before it gets better
so for me that's not the real test it's
not about opening up now what it does
it's do we have to bring in measures
later this year which of course
nobody wants to do and the fact that he
and boy johnson keep talking about the
irreversibility
of this plan shows that you know that's
for them is the key focus as well
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight sebastian payne
and anne mccowell boy
and we will take you through the papers
continue to go through the papers
starting uh
this section with the mail and this
story about that the possibility of
migrants
being arrested for trying to um cross
the channel and this is due with a
a new law to be announced tomorrow
sebastian
yes this is something that's been going
on quite a long time and a lot of
right-wing campaigners people like nigel
fraz have been highlighting this that
over the past couple of months and
thousands of migrants have been coming
across
the english house to the uk and these
small dinghies which is a very very
perilous journey that they make and it's
created a big problem
for the uk border force who don't really
know how to manage it
and that the people i've spoken to
within government about it seems to say
a lot of the issues are to do with
france here that normally
the uk pays a lot of money and has
various agreements that france stops
people from leaving france and coming to
the uk
that's not happening so the mayor is
announcing tomorrow that there's going
to be a new law that would basically um
allow migrants to be arrested who come
over the english channel
and but i think this is a story that's
been going on for quite a long time
i think it's one that could actually
dominate the summer we have seen this
before
in the uk but whereas in the past there
was more cooperation with france
in the current times with the current
state of brexit and testy relations
between france and london
it's a lot more difficult for boss
johnson's government to fix this
and should this be a criminal offence
because these are
asylum seekers well there are also
asylum seekers who are coming from
another country which would be a safe
country in europe largely i mean that
that is i think what uh
pretty patel is really aiming at here
the home secretary with this that
yes it is true that uh britain has found
itself in a difficult
position but this is not unusual i mean
if you look across europe neighboring
countries or
countries that sort of share a part of
the sea and coastline where migrants are
are trying to come through routes which
are
not through the asylum but not through
the form of the silence
all have a problem of this nature so the
question really is
how would you go about it in a way when
you pretty much talk about being safe
and legal
i think what people will want to know
who care about the asylum system is that
the asylum system still works and it is
still intended
to allow those who would have a genuine
claim on asylum in the uk
to get here i.e that it's not just a
kind of battleshipping exercise
to keep as many people out as possible i
think there's some more reassurance that
we would need to have on that
but you know she does have some sort of
a point on what you call the pull factor
in all of this
if you see those numbers going up at
first people will say well it's only a
few people coming as
illegal uh claimants for asylum but
those numbers go up very fast because
people smugglers make an immense
amount of money out of it and so this
legislation would be very tough
towards them and would target them more
i still wonder how practical it is
because it would mean that some of these
arrests with very draconian
potential sentences would have to be
made at sea
and that is something where i think
border force and how that actually works
in practice yeah the implementation is
actually very difficult and actually
quite dangerous so i i'm not giving it a
clean bill of health but i think i do
understand
why this has come about at the time it
has but but the implementation as you
suggest might be um
problematic um very quickly sebastian uh
how much would you pay for euro
semi-final tickets
uh the mail is claiming some people are
paying 5 000 pounds
not 5 000 pounds is the answer to that i
absolutely love watching the match
with a couple of friends um on on
saturday evening we'll probably do the
same thing again
but yeah there's some extraordinary sums
of money being passed here obviously
as england played an absolute blinder at
the last match and clearly
um everyone wants to be there for the
semi-finals but yeah the
rampant touting has always happens at
these euro games and they're trying to
do various things with photo id and
locking into accounts but it never
really works people always find a way
of passing on tickets um i would pay
maybe a couple of hundred pounds but i'm
very happy
watching a mat at home a couple of
hundred from
sebastian and i suggest by your smile
that you wouldn't pay five thousand
pounds
just laughing at the thought i i i am
the woman
viewers judge me as you will who's
signed their other half who's been
loving the football up to a dinner on
the night
of course not even thinking that this
could ever happen that we'd get this far
thank you so much we shall see you in
the next hour
thank you for taking us through the page